so why should every single real estate
agent use YouTube and how can service
Professionals in general use video use
social media to grow their brand get
clients get leads I'm here today on the
podcast with lloyda Velasquez who's got
85 000 YouTube subscribers she's been an
agent she's now helping agents she's
crushing it on YouTube she has all kinds
of tips about what camera what video
strategies and so if you want more
clients and customers even if you're not
a real estate agent you're going to love
this episode of the podcast but lloyda
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you for having me so give us a
quick background on your journey in a
nutshell you were an agent for a few
years in California now we're here
recording in Miami what's kind of been
your story over the last couple years so
pretty much before I got into real
estate I worked in marketing and
advertising and I remember being brand
new in the business 2015 I got my
license I had heard about cold calling
door knocking what you got to do and I
remember going on YouTube because I
wanted to know exactly what that was
like and I wasn't finding any content at
all so I saw that as an opportunity for
me to put out my journey and start
teaching agents initially it was just me
you know picking up my phone and iPhone
6 uh creating a video as to what I had
learned that day maybe someone yelled at
me maybe I didn't have a best experience
but that's what I took as content for
that day and I just started posting
videos my goal was one a video every
single week I decided to be consistent I
knew it wasn't going to be easy I had no
experience ever doing video or public
speaking or anything like that so I
started doing that over time I was still
focusing on selling homes but I saw that
I started to get a following on YouTube
from people that could relate to me when
I first started there were not a lot of
women talking about real estate not a
lot of people that looked like me that
were my age all you saw were older men
talking about real estate and they were
coaches they were not out there making
calls or doing anything like that so so
I grew my YouTube channel I was still
doing transactions and then I got to the
point that I was getting questions all
the time from Agents that were asking me
you know what scripts do you use what
Gallery do you use so I saw that as an
opportunity also to start creating some
type of program to help agents because I
saw a need for that so that's what I did
in 2020 so it took me some time but
that's kind of when the light bulb
switch went off and I decided okay you
know there's something more here that I
need to start to monetize or see what I
can do because it's not only going to
help me but also help agents and that's
kind of where my YouTube channel has led
me and now it's just led to sponsorships
Partnerships coaching programs I mean
you name it there's probably stuff that
I'm doing that's amazing and so let's
start with the question why video and
why YouTube for real estate agents why
should they be investing their time in
it and especially in a 2022-2023 world
things are a little slowing down out
freezing a little in the market why do
you think it's so important that agents
be creating content you have to be
creating content from my experience
which is what I'm going to talk
the moment that I started to create
videos I knew my clients were looking me
up
so if you didn't know me I gave you a
call I sent you my information what
you're going to do is you're going to go
on Google look up Lloyd of Velasquez see
what pops up and since YouTube is a
search engine I started popping up so
any agent that has not taken advantage
of that they're missing out on this
opportunity for possibly their clients
looking them up and see that they are
actual agents doing some type of real
estate transactions content or or
anything like that so any agent I always
say this all the time you want to be
putting yourself out on video because
this is the first impression that you're
going to make and if you come across as
a knowledgeable agent that knows what
they're doing that can deliver some type
of value to the client they can know 20
different ages but the moment they see
you on a screen they're gonna think like
oh she's like a celebrity now and that's
kind of the effect that I have had with
certain clients where I call them we
meet up for an appointment because they
either want to buy or sell but by the
time that I get there they feel that
they have known me because they have
have been watching me all this time and
it just makes the conversation so much
easier than the referrals later on come
out because they tell their friends and
their family you know this girl lawyer
you got to watch her on YouTube because
she knows what she's doing and she's a
really good real estate agent wow so it
accelerates the currency of business
which is no like and trust people get to
know you they start to like you they
trust you and you also mention it's an
authority Factor you almost kind of like
micro celebrity yeah you're like wow
I've seen your videos and now you're
doing this walk through with me and so
it can help you drive ultimately more
deals but what would you say to the
individual that's like okay but I'm
terrified to get on camera I maybe I
don't have the Charisma or the
communication skills that you have what
are some of what's your advice for
alleviating those fears and getting
started when it's kind of overwhelming
to put yourself out there yeah I'm glad
that you're bringing that up because I
was exactly that person no experience I
did not know how to talk to a camera it
was just weird picking up a camera and
talking to it even growing up I was a
very shy person I guess you could say I
would hate speaking in public I remember
being in college and in high school if
the teacher wanted to volunteer I would
be the person that would look down to
make sure no eye contact to be called on
so the fact that I'm doing this now I
mean it just didn't happen overnight it
was a lot of practice
um but what really took it for me was
that I knew that if I created a video
and someone watched it and it led to a
transaction that video potentially could
mean a 10 15 20 000 commission check for
me and that was enough to motivate me to
do it even if I didn't feel like doing
it even if I was not an expert and when
I started my YouTube videos I remember
sometimes people would comment and they
would say oh you're talking too fast or
you're not smiling and I'm like okay
well I'm putting out really great
information but you're focusing on the
wrong thing but you know what that's not
gonna let me stop me that's not gonna
stop me so what I'm gonna do instead is
that I'm gonna take that I'm gonna watch
every video that I put out to see what I
can improve on and that's how I have
gotten better with my communication
making sure that when I do videos I'm
always smiling and then at the end of
the day I feel that's a way that people
have been able to connect with me so
when they meet me in person they're like
you're just exactly like what I saw in
video
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
that's amazing and then what would you
say when someone has a fear of the gear
so they go okay I'm gonna do it I see
the light at the end of the tunnel that
I could build trust with potential
clients but also 5 10 15 20K commission
check I gotta do this how do I start you
mentioned iPhone 6 when you started if
you give people the simplest setup to
start making videos and editing them all
these overwhelming details what do you
recommend I would say get started with
your cell phone nowadays every single
phone has 4K capabilities so you don't
need to ex to spend hundreds of dollars
on a camera I did my first two years on
YouTube just using my iPhone 6 so it was
nothing crazy nothing fancy I was going
to be consistent posting but once I was
at that two-year Mark I was like you
know what I have been consistently doing
this I'm going to invest in a camera
because I want the quality to get better
so that's when I invested in a camera
but if you're just getting started I
would say with your phone and just
purchase a microphone phone maybe
somewhere to put your cell phone on a
stand lighting if you want but if not I
would shoot every single video outside
during the day because it was natural
sunlight and that's pretty much how I
started it was nothing crazy no tens of
thousands of dollars invested in
equipment and I feel that nowadays
that's what stops a lot of people from
actually getting started because we see
so many videos even myself I mean you
guys put out so much great content on
cameras and equipment that we think we
need to go and purchase all of this to
get started but in reality just with
your phone is is a great beginning
that's a really good point and we also
will link up in the show notes whether
you're listening on audio or on video
the YouTube description
um some some of our best simplest videos
for accessorizing your smartphone I
agree you get a little smartphone stand
some you know plug-in mic and there's
different ones you could get kind of
like a almost like a podcast mic with a
stand or just a lav mic like we're using
to record this podcast so we'll link
those up in the show notes if you're
looking for the gear but you mentioned
scripts and you mentioned like ideas
what what do I even talk about now what
are the best videos that I can make as
an agent to start getting more deals
start creating content around where you
live people want to know what it's like
where you live the pros the cons the
shops coffee shops interviewing the
places that you frequently go to because
chances are that the owners or the
workers have already seen you and you
can already start building those
relationships so I tell agents if
there's a coffee shop that you're always
going to see if they're open to doing a
quick interview where they talk about
their shop how long they've been there
what they offer because now that's a
great way for you to build that
connection with that owner then that
owner can share that video to their
Network and they're going to be super
excited it's free marketing so that's a
great way for you to get started and get
known within your community along with
that you know tips on like I said you
know when you list different things the
pros and cons but the community I feel
is the one that would really establish
any agent easy to do you just actually
have to go out there and do it it's
amazing well you heard it now there's no
you got to punch fear in the face and
press record you've got got to just grab
your smartphone the why is for sure
especially in a highly competitive
market I think how can you be
anti-fragile in recessionary times in
times when transactions are maybe going
way down someone's still going to be
doing the deals yeah the most known
agents the most seen agents the ones
that have the most trust
and so you got to go all in on YouTube
if people want to learn more about you
and learn more from you shout out your
stuff yeah so you guys can go to my
YouTube channel it's just my name Lloyd
of Velasquez website Lloyd of alaska.com
and then on Instagram just lloydavillas
amazing and if you want to check out
actually part two of this podcast we
talked about how to turn your knowledge
and experience into cash at some point
maybe you've been doing what you've been
doing for a long time and you're ready
to kind of move more into coaching then
definitely check that episode out on the
think media podcast
foreign